oggi parliamo di mercato dei farmaci
mercato dei farmaci e dei loro prezzo
e bisogna capire il mercato dei farmaci
come funziona il punto di vista
economico ma il modo migliore per capire
quanto costano le medicine che noi
andiamo acquistare tutti i giorni quelli
che ci permettono di curare e di vivere
un evento traumatico dobbiamo un po'
capire come funziona questo mercato del
fatto di grandi multinazionali grandi
imprese
che si rapportano poi un sistema
sanitario pubblico alle nostre
Assicurazioni sanitarie che paghiamo in
Italia tramite delle tasse e vediamo
come si interfaccia in quale la il
rapporto che abbiamo tra queste grandi
imprese tra i nostri sistemi sanitari
tra i medici che prescrivono e noi
pazienti che assumiamo questi farmaci
Allora per spiegare il mercato
farmaceutico sono solito utilizzare una
metafora Allora ipotizziamo di fare una
cena una cena tra tre persone e quindi
di essere stasera in un ristorante in
cui
è presente il paziente il medico che si
danno appuntamento presso questo
ristorante E il paziente arriva e si
siede al tavolo il medico arriva subito
dopo Intanto il paziente non ordina
niente perché non ordini niente perché
arriva il medico che apre il menù e
ordina al paziente quello che quella
sera il paziente deve consumare Quindi
quello che noi chiamiamo le prescrizioni
del medico
e il medico chiude il menù non guarda
quanto costa chiude il menù ordina al me
alla paziente quello che deve consumare
quella sera e dopodiché si esce va via
Perché rimane solo il paziente a cui li
portano poi quello che il medico gli ha
ordinato consuma e la cosa importante
che il paziente finisce di fare questa
cena si alza dal ristorante ed esce
senza pagare come senza pagare e si esce
senza pagare perché subito dopo entra il
nostro sistema sanitario nazionale
che paga per tutti che paga per il
paziente che paga per il medico che paga
al ristorante e poi io sono solito dire
siccome insegno a farmacia Chi è che
porti i farmaci Allora i miei studenti
di farmacia mi dicono Eh beh lì sono il
farmacista Insomma il sistema sanitario
che paga questa questa cena Un pochino
particolare cioè capite quindi il
mercato farmaceutico è fatto di qualcuno
che prescrive dei prodotti noi
consumiamo non abbiamo bene la Chiara
consapevolezza di quello che abbiamo
bisogno avvertiamo un dolore avvertiamo
Una specifica sintomatologia che data da
una malattia e e consumiamo quello che
ci è stato prescritto
però poi non lo paghiamo perché entra
un'assicurazione sanitaria o nel caso
italiano il nostro servizio sanitario
nazionale che paga per tutti noi
bene Questo è un po' il mercato
farmaceutico nelle sue caratteristiche
Allora volutamente teniamoci in mente
questo questa cena particolare tra tre
persone perché adesso andiamo a
capire tutti gli elementi che
caratterizzano questo mercato perché ci
sono magari farmaci che costano tanto e
perché la ragione che stanno dietro a
queste costi elevati perché un sistema
pubblico cerca di risparmiare le risorse
No perché se non ci mettessero dei
controlli alla spesa la spesa sanitaria
esploderebbe Allora andiamo con ordine
andiamo con ordine ricordando sempre
questa cena particolare tra tre persone
primo elemento il mercato farmaceutica
ha una prima peculiarità Allora si parla
come dicevamo di
ignoranza del consumatore o meglio il
consumatore non sa quello che deve che
ha bisogno ma lo acquista no Pensate se
voi andaste In un mercato è un
supermercato e ci fosse qualcuno che vi
dice che cosa comprare No è così nel
mercato farmacia c'è c'è qualcuno che vi
dice Come comprare al paziente il
paziente assume e poi non paga quindi
c'è una sorta di richiamiamo economisti
ignoranza del consumatore Cioè o meglio
una simmetria informativa il paziente
tra virgolette consumatore di farmaco
avverto una sintomatologia ma non sa che
cosa c'è dietro questa sintomatologia e
si appoggia un medico per la scelta
primo aspetto prima problematica di
questo sporcato particolare
seconda problematica di questo mercato
c'è un medico che agisce in nome per
conto del paziente noi economisti
Diciamo che il medico è un agente
imperfetto in nome per conto del
paziente Cosa vuol dire un medico agente
paziente e significa una cosa molto
semplice che il medico si fa incarico
delle problematiche del paziente cerca
di trovare una diagnosi sulla base delle
sue studi e della storia clinica della
sua consapevolezza del numero dei
pazienti che ha visto E chi cerca di
trovare una soluzione
ma nel fare questo il medico ha una
propria funzione di utilità un proprio
interesse diciamo Cosa vuol dire un
proprio interesse Beh che la letteratura
scientifica è ricca di queste
affermazioni che in funzione di come io
pagherò il medico stipendio notula
collaborazione il medico Si potrà
comportare in modo diverso con il
paziente questo è un altro problema
perché il medico nel tradurre in
prescrizione la sintomatologia del
paziente
alcune proprie funzioni di utilità
quindi
deciderà di fare
qualcosa Magari anche in funzione di
come pagato per esempio una volta gli
ospedali
erano pagati per giornate di degenza e
quindi sono sostanzialmente i pazienti
avevano e gli ospedali avevano interesse
che i pazienti stessero tanto tempo in
ospedale oggi Gli ospedali sono
remunerati per caso no Quindi per
prestazione effettuata indipendentemente
dalla durata della giornata di degenza e
quindi le giornate di jazz si accorciano
e quindi cambia anche l'approccio
clinico del medico quindi altro aspetto
importante nel mercato farmaceutico così
poi come in tutti i mercati sanitari e
come paghiamo il medico avremo delle
differente soluzione che il medico può
dare al problema del paziente questo è
una grossa criticità di questa famosa
cena tra tre persone la terza
caratteristica del questa cena
particolare di questa cena tra tre
persone guidata dalla presenza del terzo
pagante ossia il sistema sanitario che
entra per il paga per tutti
il fatto che le spese per la salute e
dei farmaci siano socializzate cioè
siano grattate gratuitamente a tutti gli
individui per l'Italia ad esempio è un
dettato costituzionale parliamo
dell'articolo 32 della Costituzione che
dice che è lo stato tutela la salute
come diritto fondamentale e fornisce
Cure agli indigenti ecco Ma per fornire
cura gli indigenti e a garantire la
tutela della Salute tutta la popolazione
questo comporta il fatto che le i
farmaci siano dati gratuitamente ma nel
momento in cui si è danno dei farmaci
gratuitamente significa che né noi
pazienti consumatori tenderemo a usarli
un pochino di più di quello che servono
Ecco spiegato il meccanismo e le
necessità che hanno i sistemi sanitari
moderni del nostro Come il nostro
attuale ha ottimizzare le spese per la
salute a spingerci quindi a consumarne
di meno o stare attenti a quello che noi
consumiamo sono tutti quei meccanismi di
consumo attenzione
per consumare di meno di farmaci
consumare in maniera appropriata
il quarto elemento caratteristico questa
cena rappresentano l'esternalità che le
nostre scelte creano sull'economia più
In generale Cosa vuol dire esternalità
significa che i nostri comportamenti
individuale possono dare conseguenze
positive o negative sulla collettività è
un classico caso quello degli
antibiotici che se lo usiamo troppe
magari curiamo la nostra piccola
malattia ma creiamo delle resistenze a
tutta la collettività e classico caso
della prevenzione
prevenzione che fa bene a noi individui
ma tendenzialmente magari non capiamo
l'importanza Ma la prevenzione di
malattie comporta poi riduzione in
futuro di spese per il servizio
sanitario
classico esempio che si fa in questo
caso sono i vaccini noi nel nostro
scelti individuale preferiremo non
vaccinarsi e fare in modo che tutti gli
altri si vaccinano in questo modo Noi
siamo coperti dalle malattie grazie ai
nostri ai nostri altri
cittadini che si sono vaccinati ma in
questo modo tendiamo a creare delle
sacche di resistenze di delle malattie e
quindi a non essere completamente
coperta la popolazione e non fare in
modo che la vaccinazione svolga il
proprio ruolo
l'ultimo elemento importante che quando
parla si parla di mercato dei farmaci
significa che siamo di fronte a aziende
che offrono bene e servizi in questo
ipotetico ristorante che sono coperti da
brevetto e quindi siamo in una
situazione di monopolio Cosa vuol dire
essere una sezione di monopolio
significa che le industrie Quando
scoprono un principio attivo lo coprono
subito dal brevetto prima di iniziare
gli studi in modo tale che non possa
essere copiato da altre aziende
sviluppano gli studi che passano 4-5
anni il dopo dieci anni di ricerca il
prodotto arriva sul mercato e quindi i
nostri sistemi sanitari si trovano a
negoziare
dei prodotti con aziende che hanno loro
la titolarità quindi una situazione di
monopolio
oggi
investire in un nuovo farmaco significa
investire risorse che va dal miliardo
miliardo e 200 milioni di euro
mediamente e quindi quando questi
farmaci arrivano sul mercato hanno un
costo estremamente rilevante sulla
collettività e quindi le autorità
sanitarie negoziano con le aziende
farmaceutiche i prezzi Sulla base del
valore che danno in termini di salute si
innesco una negoziazione che può
determinare Quindi anche rilevanti
prezzi per il sistema sanitario
Ma tutto questo Quindi avremo in futuro
prezzi sempre più elevati dei farmaci
Beh Fortunatamente no perché esiste la
concorrenza dopo vent'anni quindi 10 di
sviluppo 10 di commercializzazione i
farmaci perdono il brevetto i farmaci
diventano quindi a brevetto scaduto e si
hanno i farmaci equivalenti o generici
quando arrivano le aziende che prendono
questi brevetti scaduti e le rimettono
sul mercato con un prezzo in genere dai
50 al 70% più caro e quindi questo
meccanismo Quando scadono i brevetti di
concorrenza tra le imprese genera il
fatto che il sistema pubblico può quindi
recuperare quelle spese che aveva
all'inizio negoziato con le aziende con
l'innovazione prezzi più alti e quindi
fare in modo che il nostro garantire la
sostenibilità a lungo termine è un
mercato molto importante questo dei
farmaci a brevetto scaduto perché noi
pazienti che abbiamo sempre piena
consapevolezza usare i farmaci
equivalenti crea quel meccanismo
virtuoso nel quale ci permette quindi di
risparmiare la Dove possiamo risparmiare
sui farmaci equivalenti e lasciare
liberare risorse per investirli
innovazione ed è questo il meccanismo
che garantisce quindi in futuro di avere
sempre farmaci innovativi e sempre
farmaci che ci cureranno per malattie di
cui oggi non ci sono i trattamenti
Quindi da una parte dobbiamo negoziare
con le autorità tra le autorità
sanitarie le industrie farmaceutiche
farmaci innovativi che siano realmente
innovativi cioè che Curino malattie di
cui non c'è un trattamento o che vanno a
migliorare magari gli attuali
trattamenti Quando scadono i brevetti in
noi pazienti e medici ci sia la
consapevolezza nell'utilizzare il
farmaco a brevetto scaduto equivalente
che costerà di meno perché le aziende
con la concorrenza offrono prezzi più
bassi e che nel contempo garantisce
quella sostenibilità quel liberare le
risorse che possono essere Poi investite
nell'innovazione nei nuovi farmaci che
arrivano Ed è proprio questo meccanismo
questo equilibrio questo Questi rapporti
che abbiamo con l'industria farmaceutica
un'industria che viene chiamata
Nel gergo economico Big Pharma cioè le
grandi industrie farmaceutiche pensate
che una tra i più grandi industrie
farmaceutiche al mondo ha un prodotto a
un fatturato che è più o meno pare
quella al prodotto interno lordo di un
paese come il Portogallo Quindi grandi
industrie farmaceutiche offrono
innovazione negoziare con l'autorità
pubbliche prezzi che possono essere
anche importanti Ma che siano il più
possibile
calati sul valore in termini di salute
una volta negoziati questi prezzi questi
prodotti rimborsati da uno Stato
territorialità sanitaria sarà poi quando
scadono i brevetti l'utilizzo poi di
formulazioni quindi equivalenti a
brevetto scaduto che ci permetterà
quindi di mantenere nel lungo termine
l'e meno nel nostro sistema sanitario e
garantirci nel tempo è l'arrivo di
prodotti innovativi che ci riescono a
curare e migliorare la qualità della
vita delle nostre malattie e del nostro
quindi è stato di salute in futuro
Grazie